[Musique]
salut je suis les cages vous voulez me
tester alors vous savez on trouvait au
j'ai tout filmé mec tout le monde parle
de l'ucas jazz comme s'il était le
message audio à lyon cela comme un axe
man l'homme noir à l'épreuve des balles
pour les petites frappes
il est le croque mitaine du ghetto qui
les landes jour et nuit toute vitesse
vous êtes sérieux il sera connaît tout
essayé au moins aino ce n'est pas
l'homme qui peut sauver toute une
communauté coup ne pouvait pas continuer
à faire ce que vous faites
je vois pas du tout de quoi vous voulez
parler écoutez moi bien lu cage n'est
rien d'autre qu'un homme harlem et à moi
waouh ça fait jamais plaisir de voir un
frère comme le kave allé au tapis
il t'a fait du mal t'es pas invulnérable
un type qui peut te [ __ ] dans cet état
à main nue ça peut pas être bon pour
arlette
faut que je retrouve bushmaster pourquoi
il fait peur à tout le monde
je vous souhaite que jeanne le savoir
étudia bushmaster sharif
[Musique]
je les avais une colère mais a même si
prix talent mais pas parfois la
brutalité ça règle le problème
[Musique]
harlem n'a pas besoin d'un héros elle a
besoin d'une oreille les ténèbres que tu
dois affronter chaque jour cela peut te
consumer tout entier
si tu le laisse faire
ne le laisse pas gagner
mais qu'on soit bien d'accord qu'on soit
clair je suis pas à la recherche d'une
partenaire s'était dit que c'est pas toi
mon partenaire moi c'est moi la vedette